as more people visit vegas the demand
for rides around town
have increased but ride share companies
like uber and lyft there's been a major
delay on that front thank you so much
for joining us tonight at 11 o'clock
i'm sasha loftis from wait times to
unexpected cancellations to even no
shows
it's really becoming a problem and not
just for visitors but for
locals as well madison kimbrough joins
us live from the strip tonight with the
latest
madison yes well people are having
trouble booking these rides it's really
the wait times and the cancellations
that are really having people up in arms
i want you to take a look as we are here
on the strip you can see tons of
vehicles out and about
it's obvious that other modes of
transportation like taxi services
have increased we just saw one just
drive by just now
we spoke to a local new age fleet
transportation company that is also
reaping the benefits of the lack of ride
share options in town
take a look we
literally sat there probably for another
20 minutes before
we even got an accepted ride and we were
trying both on our phones
both at uber both had lift up and
nothing
the ride share demand has increased as
more and more people come to vegas
but it's not just tourists that are
using these modes of transportation
for locals the struggle is real and they
are not happy about it
people were pulling up thinking it was
their ride and
then you could tell people were just
doing the same thing we were sitting
there looking
at their phones seeing if they would
even get a ride i
see them i see the driver they you know
and then
all of a sudden we found you another
driver
i mean one saturday i was supposed to go
to work just for a little while i waited
over two and a half hours
so why is this happening well there are
a lot of factors that contribute to the
delays
one being the obvious covet 19. many
drivers not feeling comfortable having
random people in their personal cars
so because of it there are less drivers
out on the roadways
inadequate pay unemployment benefits and
rising gas prices
all are big concerns for rideshare
drivers too captain
a new age fleet transportation company
in vegas says it's vital for these
companies and their drivers to have
honest communication with each other
during these times drivers have to be
understanding of what they're coming
back into from a work
workforce standpoint and i think we all
have to do a better job as employers
in this category to be explaining to the
drivers and educating them
about the value propositions of what we
can provide captain is not a ride share
company but a luxury private car service
and while their prices are higher they
have seen a nice increase in local
business
and now currently captain has about 150
full-time drivers and they are actively
recruiting so we'll have that
information
up on our website reporting live from
the las vegas strip madison kimbrough 8
news now